Florida the story of hurricane Ian's
Devastation it's still unfolding more
than 100 people were killed and the
recovery could take years President
Biden toured some of the damage
yesterday with Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis a possible rival for the 2024
presidency Nancy Cortes is at the White
House Nancy good morning
good morning Nate yeah crisis sometimes
makes for strange bedfellows and in this
case with so many Floridians suffering
President Biden and Governor DeSantis
had no choice but to make peace for now
Mr President welcome to Florida months
of sparring gave way to warm Wards
Wednesday as the governor and the
president toured the devastation wrought
by Hurricane Ian what the governor's
done is pretty remarkable
over the past year the two have Tangled
over masks vaccines inflation and
immigration millions of people come
across illegally since Biden has been
president at one point DeSantis even
accused the president of hating Florida
Mr Biden called DeSantis Un-American
after he flew migrants from the border
to Martha's Vineyard it's an American
it's Reckless but on Wednesday Mr Biden
had nothing but praise for the man who
could be a political rival in 2024.
[Music]
for the first time Wednesday residents
of hard hit Sanibel Island were allowed
back temporarily to assess the damage
and gather any belongings he wasn't
being in an episode of Walking Dead was
just amazing it's just some video this
is such a peaceful place and it's a
beautiful place
but it's just completely a story it's
amazing in Cape Coral makeshift medical
units have been set up to help lighten
the load on local hospitals well these
people their their primary care doctors
are closed they've got nowhere to go
before leaving President Biden made this
Frank prediction about Florida's efforts
to bounce back it's going to take years
for everything to get squared away in
the state of Florida
fully recover and rebuild we're not
leaving until this gets done
and the work continues in Florida
President Biden said there are more than
4 000 Federal Personnel on the ground
now and that includes FEMA which has set
up mobile registration centers to
process applications for assistance Nate
Nancy a comment the president made to
the mayor of Fort Myers Beach yesterday
has gotten some attention I want you to
check it out take a listen
[Music]
foreign
thing I learned when I transitioned into
TV the mic is always on
um what do you make of this hot mic
moment you know the president has
learned that lesson a time or two
himself this is not the first time that
he's been caught using salty language on
a hot microphone the mayor he was
speaking with there mayor Murphy said it
was just two guys talking that the
president wasn't aiming that comment and
anyone in particular he says he doesn't
remember exactly what it is he said that
prompted the president to have that
reaction but apparently White House
aides aren't that phased by it because
once the comment went viral they ended
up tweeting it out themselves
um well most of us have been guilty of
it Nancy thank you